fiction another Frontier in the culture
wars what's playing out within
publishing set to affect what ends up on
bookshelves near you not Sense and
Sensibility but Common Sense pitted
against sensitivity take Roald Dahl for
instance when plans emerge to publish
re-edited versions of some of his
Classics removing words like fat and
ugly it caused uproar with the likes of
Sir Salman Rushdie saying it was
censorship
a sensitivity reader despite the name is
not looking for offense we're looking
for harm
increasingly these days Publishers now
employ experts like Helen gold people
who do not experience oppression maybe
don't understand how important it is not
to be reminded of
um all the atrocities that you and
people who share your identity have gone
through
she believes the media's portrayal of
sensitivity readers as unqualified
outside forces is in part fueling online
outrage
we are more like specialized editors
in the same way that if you're writing a
book about a hospital you might want to
go and talk to a doctor about what they
do say a white author writing about
black characters might want to go and
talk to a black person about what it's
like to be black
how do authors see it Harlan Coburn has
sold over 80 million of his Thrillers
Abby Morgan is an award-winning
screenwriter and author
the world is different and so you have
to reflect that my novels take place in
the present day so my characters will
speak now differently than when I wrote
a book in 1989 or something like that
they should speak differently the world
is different we're trying to revise and
look at history and and really
re-examine the way we we've looked at
history for example we're going to do
that with literature but also it's
important I think those things exist so
that we can name them and expose them
and say that was the time when those
things were written and that's not the
way we would choose to right now but
that's what was acceptable or written in
the way
um it was in that time and so for me
it's a real balance in reality modifying
what's written with sensitivity is of
course likely to be less about
Publishers writing a wave of political
correctness and more practically about
sales ensuring books have a longer shelf
life that what's written stays relevant
okay to spends at Sky News